y pensé de usar velcro para esto e
incluso intenté pegar el velcro en la
parte de atrás de las baterías pero no
se quedaba pegado y mientras coloco esto
quiero asegurarme de que quede así con
la parte superior viendo hacia arriba
para que cuando lo jale se vaya
ajustando en la parte de atrás no tienen
que ajustarlo por completo aunque no se
debe de mover y las baterías deben de
quedar firmemente colocadas
ahora ponemos el otro cinto del otro
lado y de nuevo queremos orientar todo
de la misma manera ya que si lo ponemos
de otra manera no sujetará con firmeza
las baterías
es muy importante que al montar las
baterías las pongamos lo más cercanas al
centro del dispositivo que podamos ya
que esto tiene la mayor cantidad de peso
cuando necesiten cambiar las baterías
solo hagan esto a un lado y así podrán
sacarlas no es algo muy sencillo de
hacer pero la sostendrá bastante bien y
es bastante barato
y ya que lo apretamos con fuerza pues
esto se va a aflojar con el paso del
tiempo vamos a cortar los sobrantes